what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation Greg here joined by Michael the Tesla
a Star Wars Professor I'm gonna start calling
you that instead listen so we already covered
the Ahsoka trailer leave a like by the way please
go ahead use the force label like you know how we
did we already covered the Ahsoka trailer you guys
go ahead and watch that now they did announce some
stuff from Star Wars when I called Michael this
morning like where you got Michael I always had a
Soaker trailer was out and I asked him like don't
read anything of what's announced man I heard
about the Ahsoka trailer and I heard of one movie
but I heard there's three actually so I don't know
any specifics I literally just saw a title of
something and I was like oh wow that's all I got
I'm like nervous so here we go Michael so I have
this IGN article pulled up here yeah lucasfilm
announces three live action Star Wars movies
or in development with directors Dave baloney
James Mangold and Charmaine obey chenoy James
mangle director of Star Wars remember he was in
talk they were talking about him doing like
Boba Fett oh God I would have paid a lot of
money for that version great Dave filoni's
film will focus on the new Republic and as
a big deal as felony has been an integral
part of Star Wars for many years okay so
proud and happy for him I did hear that his
movie is going to take place that is one of
the things I saw would take place after uh
episode six before episode seven amazing so
as we have all been thinking building up to
that big cinematic event yeah to tie it into
here that Gap with like Mandalorian and Ahsoka
right what a task did you read this Michael
oh my God Daisy really returning to Star Wars in a
movie set after the rise of Skywalker as mentioned
in the blurb above Daisy Ridley will officially be
returning to Star Wars Rey in a new movie set 15
years I didn't know that after the events arise of
Skywalker wow in this new movie oh that's the one
directed by Charmaine Rey will attempt to rebuild
the Jedi Order as a Jedi master so we can get
more Jedi movies it's almost like what we wanted
the first time yeah yeah while I am skeptical of
anything in the sequel era I personally feel
like uh Daisy Ridley John boyega oh damarin
so beautiful the talent that they found were so
good I'm really excited for all of them to have
the opportunity to like really really do what
they do best I'm impressed and surprised in
equal measure I think the gut instinct for Disney
was to like never talk or think about the sequels
again and and I appreciate that with a bit of
time a bit of refinement that we can give maybe
some of this amazing cast uh the opportunity
to really shine do you think John boyega will
return I hope he does oh oh me too I think
that of all them jumbo got the absolute crap
end of the stairs set up and they just totally
put them like if they don't open with him as a
Jedi Knight I'll be real angry I also want to
know what happened with the kid with the broom
yeah is he still sweeping somewhere uh using his
limited Force capability it's just a sweet but no
especially for Daisy Ridley where it's like rise
of Skywalker especially was so pan but I feel like
she really poured her heart and soul into those
movies and regardless of what you think about
those films I think Daisy Ridley did excellent
work it's the kind of thing kind of like what we
see with the guy who plays Jar Jar Binks on that
best I love that you're comparing Rey into the
judge our picture of the idea of like oh man this
person has such like a negative relationship with
Star Wars and now they get a chance to redeem
themselves yeah and do something special and
different I'm excited to see where they go with
it I'm super curious because you know with with
Palpatine gone again for the a couple times now
who is the big bad like I'm I'm curious are they
going to go down the same old Rabbit Hole or
are we going to introduce something new well
that's what I find cool about it is because it's
saying that's focused on her billion Jedi Master
building a new order they would be doing like
a continuation it's not a fill in the Gap a
segment of Star Wars they'd be doing something
that takes place after the main Skywalker Saga
but it wouldn't be epic so 10 you know yeah and
I think that's a really cool direction to do it
because this would be the first time we have
something that takes place after Skywalker
Saga that is not an episode something it would
be its own thing maybe I'm presuming it might
be episode 10 yeah and it's an unexplored well
she is a Skywalker yeah sure she is a race it's
an unexplored time period the thing that I'm
genuinely most excited about in Star Wars right
now is that for the first time in forever we have
like an ominous villain that exists without out of
the realm of anything that we've ever dealt with
or anything that we've ever seen in in the form
of you know the potentially the grisk uh in in
Ahsoka getting out of just the Jedi and the step
is really exciting so is it going to be called
the new new Republic yeah the newer Republic the
newest Republic okay yeah so they do confirm that
filoni's movie will take place after the events
of the Return of the Jedi before Force awakens it
will close out the interconnected stories told in
the Mandalorian book of Boba Fett Ahsoka and other
New Republic focused Disney plus series looks like
they want to conclude the shows that are doing
some of the best for Star Wars right now well
for now yeah I'm sure they'll find a way to give
every secondary character their own spin-off from
that but I think it's just great that Dave filoni
is finally getting a chance to make a movie I mean
we've talked about it forever of of giving him
that mantle and and the creative Liberty I mean
based on what we saw from the Ahsoka trailer it's
hard not to imagine it's gonna be a crazy Star
Wars movie I mean just that one episode he did
of season two was phenomenal one of my favorites
of the whole series he just has such a great
attention to George's original Vision he's such
a cinephile and from so many different cultures
and perspectives and he really just like pulls
the best of everything which I feel like Star
Wars at its heart is just this like collection
of great of other movies yeah all kind of put
together with this like amazing lore glue that
nobody knows better than Dave filoni well you see
that's the funny thing with that episode six that
came out of the Mandalorian there were a lot of
people were like it's like a Clone Wars episode
it's like a cloners episode and to me I you know
and I think of Clone Wars like sure are there some
goofy silly fun episodes Absolutely but there's
also some of the most intense most serious some
of the best Star Wars has ever been yeah from
clone wars that my mind immediately goes to
like that was some of the most gripped I've ever
been and it wasn't a goofy thing at all and then
with James mangold's movie what they have here is
it's going to take place at an early point in the
Star Wars timeline we came up with an incredible
story to tell about the dawning of the force okay
whoa yeah I mean I'm I know they put a lot of time
and energy into like well the high Republic period
I think Star Wars fans forever uh since the
Knights of the Old Republic video game series
came out forever and ever ago to see the origins
and to see the beginning and there's so much like
how did everything take shape like how did the
first like Sith be like break from the Jedi and
the Jedi Civil War I mean I'm really curious as
to what time period exactly they're going to cover
because some of it is Canon other parts are not
yet defined it's just exciting to I want to see
coruscantes Rock when it was just a rock what if
that's the whole movie it's just like an ethereal
well he's like he's like on a mission or she is
on a mission uh to like find the force they climb
this mountain and at the very end we cut two and
it's just Pershing licking the lollipop whoa it's
the same man well in Clone Wars we had the mortise
are and that really seemed to delve deep into
yeah yeah I mean it's every time I think I've
wrapped my head around what they think the force
is they continue to didn't dig a Little Deeper it
would be really neat to go back to some locations
that we've seen you know some of the ancient
sites like sure where we picked up with with
Luke uh in force awakens skelos uh which is the
actual name of the island that'd be so cool to
see that like as like an actual Jedi Temple or to
like see the building of the original Jedi Temple
and Coruscant like stuff like that does it for
minority self well [__] man there's a lot here
there's a lot which one are you most excited
for my my gut says Dave filoni in my opinion
is the most deserving wonderful Soul people in
the film World kind of look down on television
I feel like people in the television world look
down on animation Dave filoni if you think about
his like rise and Ascension and his ability to
honor George's original Vision while also like
embracing the fans and hearing them and evolving
and growing as a Storyteller I just feel like he's
going to tell a story that is the culmination of
his entire Star Wars career thus far I mean all
of these dots are threaded together I think that's
a pretty extraordinary thing and regardless of if
it's my favorite Star Wars movie I think it's the
one I'm most excited for because it's nice to see
somebody who genuinely loves this and lives it in
the same way I think a lot of Star Wars fans do
finally have that chance to really play with the
big boys I mean directing a Star Wars film is no
joke yeah the other one sounded really fun though
I'm really jazzed alrighty guys well which one of
these announcements are you most excited for leave
your thoughts down below be sure to subscribe
leave a like keep a look out for our Mandalorian
reaction to the force I'll see you guys soon